il va s'illuminer à partir du 26
novembre prochain et n'attendra plus que
vos chaussettes le sapin de noël de la
place jean jaurès à tours vient de
réintégrer son emplacement habituel près
des jets d'eau après une année d'absence
cette fois ci la municipalité a réussi à
trouver un généreux donateur du côté de
saint fons les vignes théodore de
queiros a suivi l'abattage et le
transport du précieux conifères c'était
ce matin regardez
cette année il semblerait que la ville
de tours est enfin retrouvé sa bonne
étoile qu'elle va pouvoir accrocher
fièrement en haut d'un sapin depuis ce
midi un épicéa de 15 mètres trône sur la
place jean jaurès après un noël sans
sapin l'an dernier les passants salue le
retour du grand conifère je suis très
content c'est du renouveau pour
ce nouveau sapin il est vraiment
majestueux je pense que ça va être
quelque chose de vraiment bien quand il
va être tout décoré ça va être
merveilleux ce beau sapin on le doit à
une famille de saint-ouen les vignes qui
a accepté d'en faire don à la ville
plantée il ya 60 ans pour la naissance
d'une petite fille les nouveaux
propriétaires cherchent un moyen de s'en
séparer depuis plusieurs mois on a un
beau but i / sous lequel on mangeait à
l'ombre et depuis trois ans il est en
train de dépérir donc je pense que le
sapin a pas forcément voilà un impact
sur lui
entre guillemets pour le faire mourir
mais il amène de l'acidité il je pense
qu'il enlève de la nourriture ou aux
autres végétaux donc j'espère saône
pouvoir sauver monde hui de bonne heure
ce matin les arboristes grimpeurs à
l'oeuvre pour élaguer la base de l'arbre
et le sortir du jardin attaché à une
grue mobile le roi des forêts est couché
à l'horizontale sur un semi remorque une
première manoeuvre réussie menés à la
baguette par sébastien robin qui
demeurent prudents l'opération n'est pas
fini il est déjà déposé ce qui est pas
mal parce que là il y avait beaucoup de
contraintes aérienne on avait des fils
électriques on avait des files ptt donc
la manoeuvre était délicate mais elle
s'est bien passé c'est par les petites
routes que l'épicéa rejoint son nouveau
jardin pour sa seconde vie sous les
projecteurs de la ville il
s'illumineront vendredi prochain